[Musique]
trois rivières c'est l'une des
circonscriptions au québec qui est
vraiment dans la mire des conservateurs
et c'est peut-être là où il avait plus
d'espoir de faire des gains en 2021 mais
la défaite a été créée fleurs ils ont
perdu par moins de cent voix
[Musique]
bonjour bien la basse
si yves lévesque l'ancien maire qui se
présentait pour le parti il raconte à
quel point il a été surpris des
résultats de la dernière campagne
monsieur legault le premier ministre a
recommandé au niveau fédéral le parti
conservateur prêt malgré ce nouvel os on
ne gagne aucun siège selon lui les
tergiversations du chef ferrer no to
reel son manque de clarté sur plusieurs
enjeux ou empêcher les conservateurs
d'aller chercher des sièges additionnels
au québec josée toujours j'ai un pelage
un plan je plains ces moments donnés oui
mais c'est quoi ton plein oui et pour
pour sassou est compliqué non plus mais
moins d'un programme la du dpt l'avait
trop s'il y avait trop mais moi je
perdais mon latin yves lévesque croit
que les électeurs québécois ne sont pas
très dogmatique ils peuvent appuyer
toutes sortes de leader pourvu qu'ils
expriment clairement ce qu'il pense
c'est un exemple pierre poilievre le
seul candidat déclaré jusqu'à maintenant
si vous l'écoutez c'est quelqu'un qui
défend ses idées d'abord en fait vu ont
choisi d'après notre discussion il rend
visite à deux admirateurs de longue date
francine et serge ont déjà voté pour
plusieurs partis fédéraux comme le bloc
et le npd mais ils ont choisi d'appuyer
les conservateurs aux deux dernières
élections ce qu'ils adorent leur
candidat local monsieur trudeau c'est
comme s'il y avait une machine argent
d'as à jouer inévitablement le choix du
prochain chef conservateur se glisse
dans la conversation va voir facebook de
police francine et serge le connaissent
peu celui qu'ils connaissent c'est l'ex
premier ministre québécois jean charest
qui songent sérieusement à se lancer
dans la course tellement de choses
dans des ports
français mais aussi à des doutes il
reste du canada ils ne s'aiment pas
beaucoup le québec gg j'ai de la
difficulté à croire que le reste du
canada va voter pour un chef qui vient
du québec son mari d'ailleurs ne sais
pas si la grande famille conservatrice
va parvenir à rester unie bien longtemps
aujourd'hui l'avenir où on se parle
le parti est en péril pour l'instant ce
qu'on entend on voit l'eau et les peaux
d'unités
on n'est qu'en haute en ce moment vers
québec qui toute mesure où les
conservateurs détiennent cinq sièges la
moitié de leurs circonscriptions dans la
province
aussi vraiment considéré comme un
terreau fertile
[Musique]
dans ce petit restaurant au nord de
charlesbourg ces trois militants croient
qu'il ya moyen de rassembler les
conservateurs roupies condition de
mettre la saine gestion des finances
publiques à l'avant plan économique avec
la pandémie s'apprêtait facile pour
personne fait pour médecins en vue et
surtout à condition de ne pas
s'embourber dans les enjeux de droite
sociale comme l'avortement dans les
chaumières les gens parlent pas de tout
ça fait consensus donc clairement c'est
la recette que préconise bien des
députés conservateurs de la région parce
que je dis à mes collègues quand je
pense à mes collègues de l'ouest ou
d'ailleurs c'est que au québec on aime
ce cas-ci modérée dans la région il ya
cinq députés pour la ville de québec
mais un autre membre du caucus québécois
craint que la base dans l'ouest ne
suivent pas est ce que eux sont plus
réceptifs à être progressiste
conservateur j'en doute honnêtement ils
redoutent une scission dans le parti et
n'est pas certaine rester c'est le
prochain chef n'est pas un progressiste
conservateur et ça inclut pierre
poilievre qu'ils trouvent parfois trop
versé vers la droite populiste avec son
appui aux camionneurs si monsieur
poilievre devient le chef du parti
conservateur du canada devait amorcer ma
réflexion pour d'autres le choix du
leader ne sera pas déterminante
importante est ce que tu es grande
salade as
tu vois l'allégeance est plus forte que
les différences
[Musique]